[Music]
if you've ever dreamt of giving up your
day job to move to the beach well you're
not alone and that's exactly what the
owners of little ram oysters did they
gave up their desk jobs in manhattan and
bought an oyster farm that's now owned
and operated entirely by women so today
they're going to show me how to shuck
some oysters and how oysters get from
the water to our plates
[Music]
i'm stephanie bassett and i'm elizabeth
peeples and we own little ram oyster
company
we are an all-female team owned and
operated
and we are off
and we're heading east to the east side
of shelter island to gardner's bed
and that's where our farm is
so beautiful
my background is as an interior designer
and stuff was in advertising and all of
a sudden we were just kind of trying to
decide what was next we got a groupon
and one evening we were taking a
shucking class
we already knew we loved oysters and we
just learned so much how to shuck them
how to taste them you know all the taste
profiles how great they are for the
environment and then six months later we
actually bought a house we had a kid and
we bought an oyster farm and here we are
[Music]
so right now we are in the middle of
their 10 acre oyster farm and they
harvest about 1.5 million oysters a year
we touch every oyster every six weeks we
picked up some cages that needed to be
worked on and we emptied them into the
tumbler
it roughs them up so it knocks all that
new shell off and what that does is it
forces the oyster to tighten its muscle
which strengthens the shell which gives
it a deeper cuff and then by doing that
every six weeks you get a more
consistent shape you have to do that
every six weeks with every single one of
those 1.5 million oysters yeah oh my god
and it takes about 12 to 18 months for
our oysters to
go to market so we love them all very
much
so this is a good example of like the
deep cup that stuff was talking about
you want it you want this because this
is a meteor oyster
right now we're putting them back in the
water so they can keep threatening and
eating and growing and they're clean and
they're good to go we'll touch them in
six weeks
[Music]
one thing that is impacting us majorly
right now are the gas prices because we
usually go out to the farm twice a day
so that's four trips so that is hitting
us
we knew it was going to be a challenge
we knew it was part of farming but just
the weather and the tides and the water
movement that drives our every single
day of work always at the mercy of
mother nature mother nature is huge and
she reminds us about that every single
day it's a good reminder
i knew that they were
delicious and i loved eating oysters but
i had no idea they were good for the
environment
they are filter feeders they filter 50
gallons of water a day
they sequester carbon and nitrogen from
the water column and so they are
actively working to clean the water and
improve the environment
so the more oysters you have in the
water whether you like them or not it's
doing good for everybody yeah
and then the next
chapter of little ram which is
our new home operation here at the
shoals
what we can now offer is this kind of
experiential aspect it's a really great
collaboration a lot of the hotel guests
come over and you know experience you
know private tours we offer shucking
classes we do a shuck truck for a happy
hour it's been a great kind of next
chapter for us
we typically shuck through
the side like here or the back we just
feel it's a cleaner way of getting in
so you gotta
cut through that top muscle release it
underneath too and that creates that
loose oyster
when you eat an oyster you should always
be looking out for a lot of juice it's
an oyster liquor you don't ever want
them to be dry you definitely don't want
them to smell
they should
have almost no smell to them
you're looking for a meat that covers
the entire shell you want that chuck
clean you're spending a lot of money on
it and the farmers are spending a lot of
time on it
the other thing that's important to us
is to connect with the community
it's how we've grown our business by
everybody who has supported us along the
way and the other new york oyster
farmers who have kind of taken our hand
and pulled us along and taught us the
techniques
you know what used to be all men it's
pretty cool being able to put five women
on the water and growing that and seeing
how the community and visitors are
reacting to it and it's fun to see how
it's all working out
just a little lemon just a couple drops
i like a little pepper cheers cheers
what a fun yeah
cheers cheers
wow it tastes like vacation
[Music]
you